[Music]
okay everybody i am so excited today
because i am joined by pro bowl
pro bowler super bowl champ host judge
and now movie star vernon davis who is
in gasoline alley which is in theaters
and on demand now how you doing today
vernon
good good i'm doing really well thanks
for asking
oh no problem man so i absolutely love
this film i love your portrayal here of
kaiser the bouncer
now do you have any past experience in
any capacity bouncing or doing security
or just protecting any of your friends
before to like help prepare for this
role
well when i first got drafted i used to
use that
i guess you could say a security guard
and he was
he looked like a bouncer you know you
had to be careful when you were
you know when you were getting because
people there were so many people
you know they knew who i was and you i
just wanted to feel safe so i use the
bouncer so i kind of embody that
experience and of course being in
in the night life space you see a lot of
security guards bouncers and
you just take in that energy and you
just
think about
what energy who do you need to be and
how do you need to
to
uh portray this character
as as a bouncer you know so you just
taking all that and you do your research
you study
and you embody all of it
yeah and it's exciting to hear how smart
you are just talking about acting
already it's really cool and i think
you've transitioned so smoothly from
playing football to doing anything
entertaining wise whether it's hosting
judging acting but was this with acting
something you always dreamed of doing
you know was this something that came to
you after football or even before
football you always thought about
possibly being an actor well i never
really thought about being an actor if
you would have told me 10 years ago
act i would have looked at you like you
were crazy because that was
that was just something that i didn't
really want to do but
as my career started to evolve and i was
started to take interest in so many
different things
i said hey i want to explore this space
so i started reaching out taking classes
and next thing you know here i am
pursuing the world of entertainment and
it's been so much fun
that's awesome it's so exciting to see
you do it now are you also now like a
huge fan of movies and tv yourself like
do you watch a lot of stuff
yeah i try to watch it as much as i
possibly can whether it's
various
platforms when it comes to streaming
and
i
make sure that i'm watching from a
technical standpoint because when you're
active you really it's hard to really
watch a movie
like i used to watch because i'm looking
for so many different things that i can
use when i'm uh when i'm in front of the
camera
yeah and it's interesting too because
you you mentioned about acting lessons
and just learning the craft and
observing and you have such an observant
mind i can tell with the roles you take
on do you bring that same commitment
though you use training in football to
acting like are you bringing that same
is that same kind of work ethic you
would use
yes i think when you're when you're
doing anything consistency
and repetition is always the key to it
so if you can apply the same things that
you apply during football then you'll
make it as far as you want to go and for
me that was staying
being the first one on the field being
the last one on the field getting to the
meetings early and just soaking in all
that information and just working you
know if you work don't complain
and
[Music]
everything will pay off
so
can we say you're the first one to set
and last one offset
you know what if i'm anything like
morgan freeman
yes i i try to be that guy was so
impressive watching him just he showed
up on time he was the last one to leave
because he wanted to have a debate with
the director about a certain scene that
he didn't fully understand he wanted to
understand
everything about what the director
wanted out of that out of that scene and
uh with his character so
you know just being around people like
that who continues to inspire us
so uh you just take it and you learn
from it but that's what i try to do
that's that's the key to it all
yeah and that's awesome that you're
already working with people like morgan
freeman and this film bruce willis so
many big stars you can learn from which
is awesome you also mentioned two cons
consistency when i look at your imdb and
what you have coming down the line you
have so many projects coming out in 2022
is that a conscious choice on your part
do you think keeping busy is important
yeah i think if you can continue to stay
busy and just plant seeds and i
i like like you talked about not too
long ago you said
is there anything that i that i can take
for football and apply to what i'm doing
now and you can take everything from
football that's why i love the simple
fact that i've been able to
um
explore
the game of football it's given me a
platform to be able to do so many
different things and i'm taking that all
those examples and experience that i
learned from it and i'm putting it into
so many the various things that i'm
doing today so
um
yeah it's all about repetition and
consistency if you have those things you
continue to apply those things which is
extremely hard it's easy to say but it's
hard to do we can talk about repetition
and and commitment all day but it's not
easy if your mind isn't in it
so that's the thing too as i ask you
because you're doing things like acting
and judging and hosting and doing
interview with me is how are you
avoiding burnout do you have any like
tips for that to not just like oh i
can't take any more kind of feeling you
know
no i think when you get in that space
when you when you've been doing it so
much and you've had if you and you've
been in that
maybe that team it could be anything i i
don't know
that everyone has
you know in their life but i know for me
being in a team setting and being a part
of a team and getting up early in the
morning at six a.m and going to training
camp being there from 8 a.m all the way
to 10 p.m
at night
you go through so many things you endure
so much the will to win attitude takes
over and you won't allow yourself to
fail so when you have that in your
system and in your body
anything that you go into you're always
going to win because you've been through
it so many other times it's just in a
different setting a different
genre you know what i mean
and you use it for your good
yeah that that's great advice and um
yeah it's cool to hear from you and now
you had mentioned you know working with
a morgan freeman and bruce wills when
you started acting though was there any
other actors that inspired your work
that maybe you went and watched some of
the work to kind of learn from in a
sense
yeah i think guys like will smith martin
lawrence
even morgan freeman those guys who i
grew up watching michael b jordan who
just hit the scene
uh is doing really well but
yeah all the guys that i looked at
as i was coming up those guys really
inspired me to
be the best that i can be when it comes
to the crap you know i'm just getting
started
but
keep applying pressure
and i'm going to try to be the best that
i can be at it that's all you have to do
like my grandmother used to always say
just give your best
and the rest will
take care of everything else to take
care of yourself
yeah that that's a great mindset to have
and
having been a star athlete
did you ever did you feel any resistance
like to becoming an actor from others
like do you feel like this feeling of
someone not taking you seriously ever
yeah i think like anything else like
when you're in it when you into certain
a certain thing
like what we just talked about if the
consistency is then you're showing up
all the time people are seeing you like
like football for for example if people
continue they continue to see me making
plays and they see me putting in the
work they're going to respect me at some
point right and just like any other
field if they see me if they continue to
see me on television and see me in films
they're going to respect me at some
point because they know that i'm putting
in the work because a guy coming from
football from sports
tapping into something else
it's hard to take them serious because
they've been doing this for so long
this is what we've we've seen them do
this is their craft they don't know this
side but
after two three four years if we
continue to see them they're like oh
okay he's doing this for real he's in it
he showed commitment he showed
he showed
um
he he's showing us that he can come in
and do this
year after year and he's showing up he's
on tv he's he's that he's at the at the
festivals he's
he's doing this so i'm going to respect
this man
yeah
look i respect you man you're showing
such amazing talent already in this
field it's exciting because i was a huge
fan of you in the nfl and that's
interesting too you've already been on a
huge stage with the nfl so do you
ever feel nervous when you act or host
or is it kind of piece of cake in that
sense for you
no i just cuz i felt i used to feel
nervous all the time when i was playing
ball
i would go out and i would be
nervous about dropping the ball i would
be scared that i would let my teammates
down
i just
the fear of failure is always going to
be with us no matter what we do so
whenever we go into something like this
i can remember that and i can relate to
it so i know that when it happens again
i'm just going to keep on pressing
forward and i'm going to put my best
foot
in front of me
and just give give my best and
see what happens
now with um football acting doing
judging hosting is there one you love
the most do you like them equally like
how are your feelings about it
i like it all but i really like the
craft of acting because i'm able to tap
into like
my past life and the things that are
going on now in my life and i can use
that as tools
and building blocks when i'm working on
my craft or specific script right and
there's nothing like being able to use
those emotions and bringing them alive
and just being realistic under an
imaginary circumstance so i love it uh i
think it's great and it's something that
i can see myself doing for a very long
time
yeah i'm excited to see you do more too
now my last question i had to ask about
this but
do you think the high you felt when you
had the catch three happen in the big
game against the saints
can that be reached again in this
industry do you strive to feel that
again somewhere in your life
um
yeah i just like like i said i just
i think
when you achieve when you when you've
achieved success you're always going to
achieve success
because you have the building blocks you
have the formula you have everything
that it takes to be able to win
and once you understand that you'll be
able to have that same success in any
genre or anywhere you go but you have to
keep that attitude you have to keep that
approach
and the moment you let let off and steer
away from is the moment
you'll fail in the moment you you won't
reach those um
you won't reach those that that place
that you're trying to go or that place
that you've been before you know what i
mean so you have to keep that in mind
yeah and that's again just inspirational
stuff um i'm excited for everyone to
check out you in this film it's out now
gasoline alley in theaters and on demand
and vernon while i'm here with you i
just want to thank you for winning me a
bunch of matchups and madden and winning
me some fantasy matchups it's so cool to
talk to you and i hope you have a great
rest of your day
thank you i appreciate it thanks for
having me